this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
minimalists
hello simpletons welcome to the
minimalist podcast we discuss what it
means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalist i feel like we need a
advertisement suck jingle we do yeah or
we could pay for it yeah we could pay
for it
we'll get like canyon city to come up
with a
a jingle for us well we're here with our
returning champion
peter rollins is in the studio has
anybody been more than three times am i
only tk coleman i think yeah coleman is
like a six-time guest
yeah okay yeah oh no i feel mvp
runner-up
okay but in my heart you're mvp yes
don't tell tk that
i love the fact by the way simpletons is
great because it's a it's a real
dig but then it's a compliment right if
you called me a simple then i'd be like
what what did you just call me
you're like no it's a compliment you
live a simple life that's very clever
it's a way to slag people off without
the knowing or the other way around
reclamation we're taking that you know
we're all acknowledging that we're a
little bit
gullible we're a little bit foolish
right ryan and i are the head simpletons
and so you know our audience we all
recognize that we
you know we don't take ourselves a
little too seriously here
well let me let me ask you all this do
you feel like
you don't have enough even when you have
too much
today we're going to talk about the fear
of missing out
fomo right also there's this term jomo
the joy of missing out
yeah and and you know it's it's
fascinating we don't think about it i
almost said the happiness of missing out
but then i wrote down the acronym like
what wait a minute
uh so so we're gonna go with joe mo in
fact uh later on the maximal episode
i've got an excerpt from our new book
love people use things
and we talk a bit about jomo and how it
applies to productivity
and we're going to talk about maybe can
apply to stuff and in the other areas of
our life
as well and the reason we wanted to have
peter here today
is we want to discuss being content in
the midst
of uncertainty there's this uh
so we're calling this episode the
lacking and
here's why it really stood out if you go
to our wikipedia page there's a
criticism and controversy section there
and
um i write a lot in that every time
someone deletes it i have to go back in
put it back up it's a real hassle just
me going in and deleting it peter going
back and reinserting
so um here's what new york time or new
york magazine
said about the minimalists though on the
surface their message is more or less
positive
there's a tacit pessimism to millburn
and nicodemus's movement
rather than trying to change this
mindset of austerity
whether through therapy politics or
protests they advocate
making do with the lack that's nice
i'm like yeah that's how how's that
criticism right i also love by the way
that your critics are like is that the
new york times
yeah like my critics are like my mum you
know it's like
as my friend would say so that's like
that's great actually
that's brilliant but that's also yes
lovely so so this this concept of
the lack making do with the lack and to
me that almost seems like
a a compliment right yeah so let's talk
about
the lack and why so many of us are very
uncomfortable
with the lack we want to lack the lack
i mean that's the that's our desire is
to lack the lack
yeah um first of all i i feel like i've
got two responsibilities on this show
and by the way it's so nice to be back
i'm loving this good to have you yeah
yeah i've been self-isolating in my
apartment so this is lovely
um first job is to give a philosophical
framework for this question lack fear of
missing out
look at the big picture and then
connected with that
is to make sure that i destroy your
audience that i make sure no one's
watching this by the end
that we do so much philosophy that
there's only one person left standing
all right my job will be done when
you're homeless
because i would love to kind of take a
like take a bird's-eye view of this
question and then
focus it in yeah so the first thing
about
it i would love to basically talk about
freedom for a second what is freedom
um and you may know in philosophy first
year philosophy class people will ask
the question
are we free or are we determined right
is there any such thing as a free act or
is everything you do
because of something else in the past
right
and some sort of free will argument
versus determinism yeah right
so you've heard that arguments and yeah
any thoughts on that by the way
i mean i don't believe we possess free
will yeah yeah that's it that's usually
i feel like i have free will but i don't
believe i have free will
that's actually my position okay well i
want to try and convince you
otherwise okay brilliant that was good i
was hoping you would say that because
right here's
here's the so on the surface totally so
determinism means
an effect has a previous cause so if
something's determined
it's got some cause of affected it
freedom would be something happens
without a cause
right so determinism has causes freedom
is something that happens
novelty spontaneously without cause and
of course the first sooner you hear this
you go well there's no such thing as a
free act
because everything has a cause cause and
effect yeah
but then you know you think about it a
bit and you go well except for the first
cause
if er like so for example if the
universe started with a big bang
the first cause can't have a cause
because then it wouldn't be the first
cause
right right so you so it would be
whatever is behind that
so even if you have a chain of cause and
effect you still have to go well what
are bites
the thing that gets it all going because
that doesn't have a cause that it's an
effect of anyway get into all these
interesting things but that's not the me
and interesting thing
um emmanuel can't try to answer this
question
and he basically said this he said that
we're all determined and animals are
determined and he calls this um
the hypothetical imperative where we
make decisions
in in light of our past in light of what
will maximize our pleasure minimize our
pain we're all doing this your cat is
doing this as snail is doing this
right well that's great
but then kant says in the midst of this
kind of like we're just on reels being
determined
something enters into our experience
that he calls the categorical imperative
and he says this is the feeling that
there's something that you should do
or shouldn't do no matter what pleasure
or pain
is connected with um you see this in
movies i like person of interest and
we've seen it but there's a
there's a cop in that who's who's
captured by the bodies
uh human resources who are a shadowy
organization in the police
and they're torturing them and they're
going to kill him and they want to know
where his friends are
and he will not give them up and they
even threaten to kill his son they're
going to kill his son and he still
doesn't give them up that's kind of the
experience of the categorical imperative
like no matter what
he's just a line in the sand now
emmanuel
kant says this pretty much he says that
this categorical imperative is not
something we know what to do with it's
not something we go okay i'm gonna
answer to it it's a feeling that derails
us it's an experience
that basically makes us feel
uh we don't know what to do
so freedom and this is this is the
argument
freedom is not an act you don't do free
acts you don't have freedom
you are freedom you are freedom in the
sense of you are the short circuiting of
the universe
in which the hypothetical imperative and
the categorical imperative
smash together and you're utterly
derailed short circuited
and that experience is the not at
oneness of the one
that is the not at oneness of the
universe with itself
so there's no such thing as a free act
but you are the embodiment of freedom so
at the same time you're saying there's
no there's no such thing there's no such
thing as a free act
there's also no such thing as a
determined act then yeah in a way
in a way it's almost like determinism is
short-circuited
it's almost like um a mobius strip it's
like you're de-reeled
you experience um an absolute
shaking of your being so for example a
cat
never thinks what is it like to be a cat
right but a human thinks what is it like
to be a human so
we enter into this space where we feel
like
we experience what kierkegaard calls the
dizziness of freedom
where you feel like there's
opportunities and choices
and you don't know what you should do
that for something like kiragor's
freedom
it's not what you do it's the experience
of
of not knowing it's almost like what
stops you
from moving it's what kind of de-centers
you
i like that yeah like so uh when i think
about a cat
for an example they don't have free will
because they're constantly just going
after
their impulse yeah i need to chase this
thing i need to chase my tail i need to
eat
i need to yeah where we have the
opportunity to
stop and consider the act or whatever
feeling we have
yeah and it's like it's like something
comes into your world
that allows us to do that because the
question is why are we like that and for
can't
you can call it the law as well but the
categorical imperative is like something
inside you where you feel
as i say it's that feeling that there is
something for example that you should do
and have no self-interest at all like
it's it's no you
may never do it well maybe it's
impossible to do it but it's this sense
in which there is
there is a call a law a demand
that that it can't cause it
non-pathological what he means by that
is not dictated by your pleasure and
pain not dictated by any of that
and it's just the feeling of it just the
feeling of it in your being
throws you for a loop it just it kind of
like just spins you into and
consciousness can be seen as
the result so this is a way of saying
almost that's why i say you don't have
freedom you are freedom
it's like the short circuiting of
biological reality
causes the consciousness to arise and
consciousness
is the uh the experience of freedom
that's why
that's very sorry sartre says we are
condemned to freedom he says like
you can't escape it to be conscious is
to be
is to experience a type of
not knowing a type of uncertainty
so freedom is a it's a feeling it's like
feeling
is that kind of what you're getting at
yeah yes very specific feeling this is
so so kant says that and then and then
kierkegaard comes along and he says the
feeling
is anxiety so that's when you mean when
you talk about the dizziness of freedom
or
or in modern terms we might say the
paradox of choice which is a very
very similar feeling where freedom or
choice these are all
these are all good things at least we
ostensibly they're good things but then
we walk into a walmart
and all of a sudden it's like well get
me out of here immediately i have too
many choice i have too much
freedom and that causes anxiety causes
anxiety
that's the absolute key and you can feel
this you can force yourself to feel it
like if you're driving down the road
and you let yourself think i could just
turn the wheel and hit the side
and then you'll freak yourself out if
you think about it enough you'll
suddenly go oh
you know because that that's that's what
kirigir calls that experience of who
or looking over a cliff and then feeling
i could jump
and then and then you frighten yourself
with that that thought
that's the dizziness of freedom and the
funny thing is
kierkegore says that that's what makes
us human
and he calls it spirit spirit
is the not oneness of yourself with
yourself spirit
is the fact that you are derailed
you're kind of like you experience a
sense of
ultra the abyss really the abyss of
freedom
and therefore we shouldn't try and get
rid of our anxiety if our kierkegaard
says and if you're trying to get rid of
your anxiety you're trying to get rid of
your freedom
right so what you have to do is find a
way to accept
and find beauty in your anxiety so it's
a very different thing
in a medical setting they want to get
rid of your anxiety right
but then it gets rid of your freedom
like the people who take out the anxiety
drugs you feel yourself
becoming more you know a little bit more
passive
yeah which is fine because sometimes we
need is too much anxiety but
the cure is to see that that is the
evidence of your freedom
i think i think the terminus of this you
know we often see people who commit
suicide because they experience
so much depression anxiety etc
and so you're absolutely right to to
extinguish the anxiety there they were
willing to give up their
absolute freedom which is you know life
and in general you're giving up
everything
at that point we have some anxious
people who are calling in
and we've got some questions for you
today peter our first one is from
emma in british columbia so my husband
toddler pat and i live very comfortably
in an 800 square foot house
and we don't have a garage or a storage
unit or anything in our parents
basements
i come by minimalism very naturally it's
sort of the way i've always done things
and my husband is on board as well
however i also have a very high change
personality
and by this i mean i like to shake
things up a lot
not in the super important areas like i
don't ditch my friends
every few years and get new ones but i
do tend to look for a new job after
three or four years
even if i'm quite happy in my job and at
home
i love to redecorate move furniture
around buy new rugs
and pillows etc even if there's nothing
wrong with what i own
so even though i always sell or donate
or give away what i'm no longer
using like it's not like there's a
cachet of old rugs or couches or
something hiding somewhere in my house
it still feels really wasteful to me to
buy new things
even if they're secondhand which they
almost always are
just because i'm bored of a color scheme
or a pattern
i get a lot of enjoyment out of
redecorating and i'm not spending money
i don't have but my husband often
remarks
but you just bought that as something
i've grown tired of is on its way out
the door already i would really like to
improve
to be able to hang onto items long term
while still honoring the fact that i
really like to change things up a lot
so any advice that you might have for a
minimalist
with a high turnover rate is appreciated
so peter we have emma here and a few
things
stood out to me she's a lot different
from me yeah so everyone has a
a need for certainty and a need for
variety to some extent
right now she has a much greater need
for variety she's calling it a
a need for high change and she she likes
to have things change all the time
and i often say people don't hate change
they hate being changed
she likes to be the person who's doing
the change so so in a way i think both
of these go back to a need for
control my control is like i want things
to be certain i want things to be the
same day after day after day
with her she's like my need for control
means changing my situation
repeatedly so that i have enough variety
that i feel
fulfilled i think both of us in that
instance are
are pursuing some symbol of a semblance
of
of of control yeah
yeah absolutely that's a good way of
saying i l i love the way you said hi
you said um security and variety is that
the way you describe
those two things yeah because in um in
psychoanalysis
there's this notion of desire and drive
and desire is conscious and drive is
unconscious
and desire is for things for
a nice cup of coffee a nice meal with
friends it's also for
you want peace and you want kind of
security in your life so desire kind of
focuses around that
and we're conscious of that drive
and this is a bit more bizarre but it'll
kind of i think we'll unpack it more
today but
is about lack it's it's where we get
enjoyment from not getting
and we as human beings kind of weirdly
have to have to bring these two things
together so it sounds like this lady is
find actually quite an interesting way
of of
of managing those aspects because she
enjoys for example
remodeling a house making it the way she
wants but then she also enjoys the
the creative process than the the not
having the kind of moving towards
something
it's about getting it it's making her
happy the pursuit that's making her
happy exactly and she's find a way a
healthy way because if you don't find a
healthy way of doing that
we talked about this with the love
episode um if you don't find a healthy
way to enjoy that
that experience it'll come out in
unhealthy ways
so yeah um drive and desire it's funny
people we don't we don't experience
drive we don't see it it's unconscious
like we never think i actually enjoy not
getting something all right you know we
don't think like that
but there is this pleasure to
bri you know breaking everything open
starting again and
recreating it's it's sort of like
seeking in a way right so
the it's the seeking for her that
i i don't think she's looking at it as
unhealthy because someone else in her
life is saying
hey you just did that but maybe maybe
what
your husband needs to realize here is
that
as opposed to the the the pursuit of
happiness it's more about the happiness
of pursuit in your case and and it's not
going to be about reaching a
for me i'm a bit of a completist even
though i know that's an error in my own
ways because it's never going to be
complete
your house is not going to be finished
right because you
especially with a personality like
emma's she she's going to
want to continue to change things to
improve things
because she needs that variety in order
to feel fulfilled
is it possible for emma or for anyone
for that matter
to actually look at that drive that
unconscious is there a way for us to
at least you know because when i think
of emma it's like there is a drive
obviously that's happening with her
can she maybe dig deep see where that
drive is coming from
and find other ways besides constantly
redecorating her house to kind of
fulfill that drive yeah that's a great
point
and yeah i think we can the funny thing
is i would argue that
weirdly we can never directly see it
because
it's almost like consciously and this
comes back to
the anxiety thing actually is so
consciously we are in the realm of
utilitarianism and we
maximize our pleasure we minimize our
pain we
we're we're pursuing things that we want
and so consciously that's all we ever
see
that's the nietzschean will to power but
but our unconscious there's this weird
thing where
we actually directly desire the not
having
we desire to shake things up and
what i would say is yeah it's a the way
you said it was beautiful
you could become aware of that dimension
of yourself you make space for that
dimension
of yourself um but you can never get rid
of it
this is almost coming back to the you
can't lack the lack the lack will always
be there
and it's about how to enjoy it how to
find a way that
that is beneficial so for example if
you're always redecorating and you're
going through your money
and you know it's going to actually
damage you financially then
then one has to find a better way to
express that lack
yeah yeah yeah so ryan yeah let me ask
you this
in with emma it seems to me like
she's not having a sort of crisis where
it's making her broke or whatever she's
ruining her household yeah she enjoys
improving and changing her home decor
right and she enjoys maybe trying out
new
jobs now there's a difference between
between that being intentional about
moving on to new things and spartanism
spartanism is sort of a form of ocd
and and people who can't stop letting go
of things including relationships and
housing and and material possessions and
everything else
it doesn't seem to me that that's the
position that emma is in it seems to me
that she wants to continue to improve
and i say if that's not
harming other areas of your life i don't
really see a problem with it i don't
either it's like uh let's say
i was really into getting new clothes
all the time and i had a group of
friends and we did this in high school
man
where we just constantly traded clothes
yeah was it not
if she if for some available it is
causing some distress
i mean there are a couple things she can
do that i that i've thought of like
you know she can set some rules up
around how often she can decorate
once a year twice a year whatever it is
um there are also i've seen these games
that you can get on ipad that it's just
redecorating games
you can just sit there and like decorate
a new house build new houses and stuff
like that
yeah uh i mean so there might be some
other outlets for her but
back to your point if this isn't like
creating a huge distress in her
household if it's not
you know is it the like the question is
is the anxiety that she's experiencing
is it from uh you know a pain that is
becoming uh you know evident in her life
or
is it the pain that she feels like she
should be having in her life because she
likes to do this does that make sense
yeah we we had bobby burke on and he he
talked about some tips we had him on the
podcast he's from uh that tv show queer
eye
he's like an interior designer and he
runs this this uh interior design
company
and one of the things that he talks
about on his his blog and other places
is you know in order to make your space
fresh you don't have to like completely
you know swap out everything that you
have and i think this could there's this
is a metaphor for something else
you can you can change a few things like
literally change the window dressing or
in other areas like figuratively change
the window dressing you can't change the
things around you
yes you can oh wait yeah
so you can you can change the sort of
accents in a room and it totally changes
the way the the place feels you can even
move furniture around
without changing the furniture and all
of a sudden you feel like you're
in a different space yeah now peter we
we have a need for
for change uh and is that because we all
just uh as humans we we're seeking more
we're seeking better
yeah well i think it comes back to your
your first question because you opened
with a question of lack
and then i talked about freedom and the
reason why i talked about freedom
was because freedom from this canteen
perspective
is the name for lack freedom is the
experience of a type of
lack in your subjectivity and being that
expresses itself in anxiety
but the idea if that's true then lack is
a part of what it is to be a subject
it's it's who we are it's what we are
and
emma gives us a beautiful example of i
think kind of a healthy way in which
lack
is integrated into one's life yeah
because there's a lack there's a sense
of
no this could be better you know this
could be different so there is a sense
of lack and there is a sense of
wanting to change but it's it's it
creates
something productive and creative um
so uh yeah i think that that this
all connects with this notion of we want
to overcome it we want to get rid of our
freedom that's why by the way sarge said
we're condemned to freedom
you know it's a weird saying because you
think we would love to be free but he
says no we're condemned to freedom
because
in some ways he says we're terrified of
this this dizziness
this fact that there's lack and we can
reimagine our lives and there's a
million ways to reimagine your life
there's a million different is infinite
and every time you make one decision you
close off a million other decisions so
it's this
and we want to get rid of that we would
love to get back on track we would love
to become
animals again yeah and that's why we
take drugs sometimes
is to get rid of the dizziness of
freedom yeah because and there's nothing
wrong with trying to get rid of it
occasionally like just to relax
because the the the the sense of
freedom is a lot to bear it's
overwhelming
it's overwhelming it's like why a lot of
people are fatigued and stuff is because
like deep down there's a lot of psychic
energies required
to to keep going that's why you know you
get drunk sometimes just to kind of
maybe
feel a little bit of an escape from the
freedom
but yeah well i'm looking at emma and
well i think we can wrap up her question
with this and
i see that maybe she's going for
something like for me
there would be some in game where i'm
like as soon as i have
x y and z again i'm a bit of a
completist here then all of a sudden
i'll give my
myself permission to feel free where as
for her it seems like the
freedom is actually in in the seeking
it's not about a particular outcome for
her because
it's like a horizon in a way once you
reach a horizon there will always be a
new horizon
so she's seeking out the new horizon and
i think as long as you're doing that in
a healthy way
it's better than the alternative i bet
you that me and you have a similar type
of apartment
i don't know you've seen my oh yeah it's
definitely similar because i mean peter
actually is more minimalist than
than
but i'm more minimalist than the
minimalist that's right but there's an
obsessiveness to my apartment
and everything is complete and it's
embarrassingly my bookshelves
i've got the books ordered by size so
that they're all
the right line because i would crack me
up if there was a book out of place i
love it
i love that the funny thing is so that
runs in my family a little bit
and at its worst you know sometimes
that can be a way of precisely trying to
you know
escape from my freedom by having
everything right so there's no
disorder in it to escape the the the
anxiety of my freedom
but that in and of itself is a disorder
yes exactly exactly yeah
that's why you know for someone the
advice is tied to your room but for
someone else it might be
mess your room up because your room is
like a morgue you've created a room that
is so tidy
that's actually a disorder you need a
little bit of mess
like i'd probably be healthier if just
one of my books was out of place
it's a little bit out of place yeah yeah
i had a friend who used to do that he
would just come in and change a book
just to see if it would mess with me
i used to do that with my ocd friends
yeah i would just like move something
around a little bit and see if they
notice it
yeah so when you talk about this the
feeling of the lack
being freedom uh you often talk about uh
the secret of the lack
is that kind of the same thing where
like if we can look at the lack
as like that's actually our freedom and
we should learn to appreciate it is that
kind of along the same lines as when you
talk about the secret of the lack
that's absolutely so there's a coin i
have
you you guys have seen that yeah it has
around the side of it i just it's funny
it's just a coin with these symbols that
describe these it looks like a very uh
like a freemason type yeah
yeah it's like a cultic thing and the
idea is like this occultic coin
yeah to make it desirable i want it to
be object a for people they really want
it because they can't get them yeah
um but along the side the words say
the lack of the secret or the secret of
the lack you can read it either way
so depending on where you start and for
me the idea is that we start with the
the lack of the secret and what i mean
by that is our natural thing is
i lack the secret there's something out
there that will make me whole and
complete there's something that i should
be doing
fear of missing out there's what is it
and we have this anxiety of the lack of
the secret
and the movement is to go from the lack
of the secret to the secret of the lack
where you go oh no there isn't something
that will complete the lack the lack is
the secret the secret to
joy and depth of meaning and creativity
and vocation is actually experiencing
the struggle and the lack
and directly enjoying it yeah so for me
the
challenge all of us face is moving from
the lack of the secret what is it what
is it i'm missing what is that i'm
missing what is it a missing to the
secret of the lack
you go i am lacking that's where my
freedom is that's where my
subjectivity is that's what it is to be
human like that's that's our it's not
the thing to get rid of
it's the highest dimension of reality
it's like it's
it's it's the universe has created
freedom it took billions of years
and freedom erupts in subjectivity it's
very impressive yeah
well the the message of minimalism is
you probably don't need that which
really means forming a dayton with the
lack
because there will always be something
else we feel that we need and
and so like if you didn't need it five
minutes ago you probably don't need it
now that that may be a good message for
for emma to hear at this point uh and
it's a good rule to follow in general
right right yeah and and there may be
exceptions to that right
and so emma i'm not saying be a complete
utilitarian here
uh in fact i think uh pete could talk
about the
the flaws with utilitarianism i'm sure
we can get into that
on the maximal but uh i think there's
there's a need
for aesthetic beauty our our friend rob
belt will talk about
you know the flowers and how they
attract bees
that's it's an essential part of their
being and beauty
is essential and so emma
what you want to do is you do want to
have some beauty in your
space but it's also realizing that it's
never going to be
perfect and and there is something that
she can do
that will fix is she could come around
and decorate my place
if she wanted to which i think is a
perfect solution
i've been feeling if she did that peter
you would you would just undo it all
like
well emma i'm going to send you a copy
of our book everything that remains it's
really
the the story of questioning the status
quo you talk about change
i think it was the the five-year period
of our lives where we went through
probably the most
profound change of our lives from our
late 20s to our early 30s
ryan and i were these suit and tie
corporate guys and became minimalists
and eventually the
minimalists and we wrote a book about it
it's my favorite thing we've ever done
it it's called everything that remains
it's a memoir by the minimalist
if you like our podcast you'll like the
audiobook version of that or if you want
the book book or the ebook version
we're happy to send those to you as well
adriana has a question but we're
short on time so we're gonna save that
for the maximal episode and
ryan let's move on over to the lightning
round all right
that's what it's time for and this is
where we answer your text messages you
can text your questions and comments
and your smart remarks to area code
937-202-4654
yes indeed those tax go to both of our
phones and we personally respond to as
many as we can we even answer some
on the podcast now pete i'm sure you'll
remember this during the lightning round
this is where ryan and i and our guests
we do our best to answer questions with
a short shareable lesson 140 character
response
we put the text to these minimal maxims
in the show notes so people can
copy and share or pick the answers on
social media if they'd like
now we've had days josh and i yeah josh
and i have had days to prepare for this
and you will have like minutes just do
this and talk for ages
i i've heard that i don't know if you
can still do it but oh 140 and then
you're five minutes
so at least five at least yes we have a
question i don't know if this is from
this peter but it's from
someone named it's from yeah it's from
someone named peter i am addicted to
phones
and accessories i regularly feel like i
need something new
different material clothing anything new
how can i stop that uh so
let's let's just i'll give you my pithy
answer and then maybe maybe you can
unpack this because i there's this term
i want to talk to you about
so my pithy answer is this new isn't
better
it's merely newer now there's this
this concept of contemporaneity
which basically means that one one way
that people use that term is that
if it's new it's better and i think
quite often we assume that if i go on to
youtube and i see like
oh someone has posted an interview with
someone i really like but then i'm like
but it's a year old
yeah why would i want to watch something
that's a whole year old
yeah i have to fight that feeling when i
see albums where i'm like oh
this is a great album great song and
then i'm like oh it's from 2016 like oh
i don't know if i should like this right
which makes no sense it's so silly i've
never heard it before
and so this this idea of contemporaneity
things are
are better if they're newer is is false
however
the opposite is also true just because
something is traditional
doesn't mean we shouldn't question that
either right
yeah i like that a lot oh that oh you
stopped there that's good you kept it
pretty pithy i like it it was only like
600
but yeah that's still not in a tweet
listen it's in a few tweets
yeah shawn will tweet something out for
me okay so now my turn
okay if i was talking to peter yeah
um i would ask i'd be interested
in whether there's some connection
between this desire for the new
and some aspect of his past like
sometimes what
we're desiring is connect for example a
person might feel that
um new things were valued in their house
or they felt old like are they
they had a new kid they were the
youngest or they're the oldest another
kid comes along and they're the new kid
and then they're kind of they feel that
they're put to the background
there's all sorts of reasons why why we
can be addicted to something
it seems weird at first but i love new
things and then you do a bit of
internal work and you realize oh it's
because i wanted to take the place of my
baby brother who was new so
it's always impossible to know what it
is but often when i when you're
interested in something it's fun to try
to make connections
with whether that connects with
something in your past and then if you
work that out
your desire for new stuff will disappear
that's the funny thing if you try to
sometimes fix this
it it doesn't work but if you can find
what it's connected to
okay yeah i'll stop there yeah you're
saying that the cause of it right
you're revealing that you're a
determinist after all
absolutely in some respects you saying
that actually makes me think
so that drive that we can never
really see but there might be some
things that happen in our lives that
have
created that drive maybe in a way yeah
yeah
they connect it's funny like so in in
analysis one of the weird things that
happens
is often an analyst doesn't tell you
something that's really hard to see
it's completely on the surface where
you'll say something
and then tweet it two weeks later you'll
say something else
and the analyst will just go oh it's
funny that you said you said this last
week about when you were young
and they'll connect it with something
you're doing now and you'll suddenly go
oh my goodness that's so clear that what
high i'm acting
to with my wife or husband is exactly
what i played out with my sibling or my
mother or my father
and and once you see that sometimes that
insight can be enough to change
one's behavior yeah so yeah it's it's
fast noon i like that all right
my pit the answer is this new products
don't equal
a new you and i think that we often go
after
new clothes or new gadgets because it's
like oh we're renewing ourselves we're
making a new i'm making a new ryan if i
update my laptop
and you know new products don't make you
a new you new actions that's what makes
you
a new you right so i don't know if you
could add that to the pithy part of it
but uh but that's really how you create
a new self is by your actions it's
interesting though
uh we we do this with like i do with my
nails that's why i constantly chew my
nails
it's because i feel like if i could just
get my nail
perfect that i'm gonna have just i'm
gonna be that much
closer to a better version of ryan i've
got you know like
be doing this to my scruff and i'll feel
like that one long hair i missed when i
shave if i could just pluck that one
long hair i'm gonna be just i'm gonna be
one hair closer
to a new version of ryan and i think we
do this with products
can you psychoanalyze this because there
is too much there
i'm not getting paid enough to me i see
i i
i associate it with anxiety as well well
you know it is an anxious tick
right but that but that's where the
anxiety comes from right there's
something in me that i'm like
i just need to be a little bit better i
just need i just need to be a little bit
a little bit more trimmed up and i could
do that by biting my nail and oh by the
way it's going to be a distraction from
the lack from the anxiety my so so i
think we're both i think we're saying
the same thing
yeah yeah well what i'm saying is you
know what what is
what is behind even that behind the
whack
if we go even if we can go farther back
like
behind the so we already determined the
y but what's the y behind the y
so i actually so my i had this
realization
uh a week or two ago i actually called
you when i had when i kind of had this
realization i don't think i went as deep
as i
uh i didn't i didn't take the
conversation as deep with you as i did
with myself but i
went down this beautiful little rabbit
hole of why
i feel anxious all the time or why i'd
get spurts of anxiety because i don't
feel anxious like right now i'm not
anxious
right but i get these spurts of anxiety
that are it's overwhelming
and uh it's the feeling of not being
uh adequate like if there is a feeling
that i
that roots back to my childhood of not
being
enough for whatever reason so that
that's the whys
is what i look at i would love to go
deeper with that um i haven't been able
to go deeper but i have realized that
all my anxiety
really does root from there's something
sparked in me that happens
in the here and now where i'm like man
if i could have just done it better if i
could have just done it differently if i
would have done something yesterday you
know like that's
the the the anxiety i experience of of
feeling like
i'm not adequate enough and that that's
the anxiety of guilt by the way so guilt
all guilt is is the sense of i am not
something that i should be so there's
there's three ways in which the lack
appears in our being
death meaninglessness and guilt so death
is the lack of being so anxiety by i'm
going to die
that's an easy one guilt is the sense of
it's also about a lack because it's a
lack of being
every time you're guilty you have a an
image of who you should be
and you don't match it so there's a lack
there's a there's a disparity between
who you are and who you would like to be
and then meaninglessness
can i pause you there because i want to
expand on that one right so so
what you're saying is your actions don't
match the person you want to be i would
just i would call that your actions
don't match your values or
the person that you value um and so um
that creates a a a type of suffering
if we don't address it and so are you
saying that if we address it in a way
that we change our behaviors
then therefore we are you we may
mitigate the suffering in some way yeah
well i would say there's like there's
two ways to address guilt
uh one way is the common way the
common-sense way we think about which is
we change our actions we try to become
who we want to be
the other technology let's call that
technology self-help
the other technology is called grace and
grace is the opposite grace is
where you go i don't have to change you
fully
but it's not the easiest what if you're
behaving like a piece of
what if you're being a piece of garbage
right this is yeah exactly do you want
to say any more about that because
that's exactly
well and so in fact my wife and i were
having this argument recently like
and actually you know what let's save
this for the maximal because i need to
talk to you about religion i thought bex
liked it when you called her garbage
only in a certain room oh yeah but no i
i want to get
into more of this um i got so much more
to talk about we
uh forget that then because i think i'll
be a great conversation oh yeah we're
definitely going to get into it because
i need to talk to you
in fact i wrote down here uh atheists
versus religious people do they equal
rep
republicans versus democrats uh we're
going to talk about that
um i want to talk about wearing masks in
today why has that become political
um and where i think ryan and i might
disagree a little bit
about this as well and maybe you can
mediate the the
the boxing match we're gonna have uh we
got some listener tips today as well
although by the way i do need to mention
this real quick we had a listener call
in a few weeks ago
and recommend there's a service called
unroll dot me i guess you can give them
access to your email and unrolls you
from all these you used to do that you
used to do it
okay it was great but also they have
some privacy concerns we'll put a link
to the article of the privacy concerns
with
that's all they come through yeah and so
i've never recommended them i haven't
used them them personally but apparently
we've actually had quite a few listeners
who have recommended them in the past
they'll always tweet me and stuff anyway
when we recommended on the podcast we
had a listener recommended
i'm sure they didn't know there's some
privacy concerns there it sounds like
they were selling some data to
uber or spotify or someone i don't know
who they were selling it so
there's a there is a article that we'll
put a link to in
the show notes we also have an added
value segment today i want to talk to
you
um about something that was hilarious
but in a way that i haven't experienced
in a long time
but first we have a bunch more surprise
questions this week like
can you avoid being trendy with fashion
and still still feel like you're
not missing out so we're talking about
trends and missing out
how do you distinguish between what you
actually need in your life and what you
think you need in your life
how do you deal with guilt when you slip
up
how much stuff is too much stuff
and what is marie kondo missing out on
this is becoming a meme at this point
that's hilarious marie kondo is our joel
osteen
okay all right so we'll get into that
but like the last i don't know seven uh
maximal episodes we've had questions
about what would marie condo do right
wwmd
wwmkd we'll get there also uh we're
gonna talk about jomo
we can apply jomo to our time and
productivity but can we apply it to our
stuff in other areas of life
we talk about the mask wearing
controversies we're going to talk about
heresy
i feel like we already have we already
hash out the mask wearing controversy i
deleted it but we're going to talk about
oh okay all right uh we're going to talk
about pyrotheology we're going to talk
about
unraveling oh yes uh we're going to talk
about a million other questions
we're going to get through that yes like
how many days
we have 24 hours that's how long our
maximal episode is that's right by the
way if you want to hear all that check
out this week's maximal episode on the
minimalist private podcast it's a
completely separate podcast
and it's just a couple bucks two bucks
and it is the most honest way for the
minimalists to earn an income because we
don't believe in advertisements so
we make money if and only if you find
value in and support what we create
advertisements suck head on over to the
minimalists.com
support to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our private
podcast play
and your favorite podcast app ryan what
else you got for us this week here are
some voicemail comments and tips from
our listeners check them out hey there
this is mckinley calling from oklahoma
city
um i just had a tip for the other
listeners i
when going through my closet um noticed
that a lot of things i held on to
just in case and so i decided to
up cycle and repurpose my clothes so i'm
not a dress person i ended up taking a
lot of my dresses
and cutting them into tops and then
using the bottom part
for creative things like headbands and
tube tops and skirts
and all kinds of things and then going
through my clothes for donations the
things that i didn't want to repurpose
or
didn't need to hold on to i put into a
bag and i saved for a
closing trade party with my friends so
all of us go through our clothes
and get donations and then sit around
and exchange them
that way we know they don't go until
landfills and that we are living
sustainably
hey josh ryan it's jack from the bay
area here in california just calling in
because i wanted to comment on rasheed
from massachusetts comment
about choosing whether to
keep things in storage for his
retirement home
something me and my wife recently did
was we let go of a couch
that we had been gifted not by
actually selling it or giving it away
but by actually asking a friend to hang
on to it
and potentially give it back to us if
later in life
we were to find a two or three bedroom
apartment or house here in the bay
that we could use it so it was a win-win
our friend got to borrow a couch and
kind of
enhance a kind of movie style garage
and we allowed ourselves to obtain more
living space in our living room with a
newer couch
that we recently acquired that
works with the aesthetic a little bit
better is a pull out for friends and
family
and ultimately just works better for us
now
all right y'all that is almost it we
have uh peter rollins here before we
thank him it sounds like he has one more
pithy
answer for us oh yes no i was just
thinking about the new the idea of the
new
is it sounds weird at first but
sometimes for like uh apple
what what's really the thing that makes
you desire it is not the computer but
the box that the computer is in
that what's happening is we're always
looking for
object a and look at the pre if you're
listening to this for the first time
there's an episode we did on object day
which is fire
yeah this object it doesn't exist but
you imagine it exists that will satisfy
you
and what these companies are selling you
with the new car the new iphone the new
computer
is often the promise that this will be
object a the thing that will fix
everything
you get the box you're that's where the
pleasure is you're opening the box to
get the amazing object
then it lets you down and so you have to
do it again the next year
so it's how do we become free from this
fantasy of the
object that is going to fix everything
and so in a way we're more addicted to
the box than the product
yeah that's good that is pithy you can
tweet that podcast sean
well peter rollins i want to thank you
for being here today i'm going to
encourage folks to check out your
podcast it's called the fun
fundamentalists and uh you can find that
wherever you check out podcasts
apple podcast spotify etc we'll put a
link to it in the show notes
also uh peterrollins.com they can find
your courses there your patreon there
your youtube channel there we've got a
bunch of new videos you've put up on
your youtube channel
we'll put a link to peterrollins.com in
the show notes
as well thank you so much for being here
today you're awesome man thanks a lot
guys well i've got an added value today
ryan you and i were talking about him on
the phone there's a
i guess you could call him a stand-up
comedian i wouldn't call this a stand-up
comedy special
it's a it's a well i think what they
call it a
stand-up show so it he
he went back to his hometown in like
alabama and played it like some dive bar
he did like
i say played he did a live stand-up show
but he also did some music
it's also part documentary his name is
whitmer thomas
the show it's on hbo
and it is called the golden one and
there are just
jokes from that that have stuck with me
that i keep using them with becks
they're really absurdist sort of jokes
but
it's the whole thing is is about dealing
with his mother's death through
comedy like we all have these sort of
ways that we try to
i know there's these cathartic ways of
dealing with
with the major life events and i think
it may have been kafka who
who said that life's most difficult uh
events can be talked about only through
jokes and and so you when you you you're
able to sort of approximate
the pain and the suffering felt from the
death of a loved one
through humor in a way that's almost
impossible to talk about head on
and so he does it masterfully in this
special and he's also
he's as silly as we ever are like it's
like
absurdist silliness from the south
and i can't recommend it enough it is
called the golden one by
whitmer thomas you got to check it out
uh for right here right now here's one
thing that's going on in the life of the
minimalists
if you want to see ryan's home and and
my home we have a tour of both
on our website just go to the resources
page on our website the minimalists.com
click on resources at the top bunch of
free resources there including a tour of
both of our
homes if you want to see how ocd i am
that's where
that's where you can figure that out i
love the note you have here bask in our
lack
[Laughter]
that's gonna lag yeah bask in the the
lack of of stuff
for sure yeah you can follow the
minimalists on facebook twitter and
instagram at the minimalist
come to one of our live podcast shows
visit theminimalists.com
tour to find a city near you when we are
back on tour but you can sign up for our
email list there
in the meantime we already have some
dates announced in the not too distant
future
the minimalists.com tour if you have a
question comment or minimalism tip for
our podcast email
voicememo to podcast at
theminimalists.com you can comment on
this episode at youtube.com
slash the minimalist and if you want our
show notes in your inbox
sign up for our email list over at
theminimalists.com you'll also receive
our simple
sunday emails and if you leave here
today with just one message
we hope it's this love people and use
things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it
bye